I'm not saying that scar is the good guy
in that film I'm not justifying what he
did like killing your brother trying to
kill your nephew is is inappropriate I
don't condone it but all I'm saying is
that you know I think the character
deserves a bit more sympathy than he
gets for one thing his name is
scar okay I don't want to get into the
nature versus nurture debate but when
you name your child scar you can't
complain when he becomes a villain
especially if we have one kid that you
named Mufasa you that strong name
Mufasa the other one you named scar what
will that make you a monkey unle so what
did you expect also I'm not saying that
Mufasa deserves to be thrown off a cliff
but there is a fundamental like moral
dishonesty to maasa that I've that I
always found deeply troubling even as a
child the first time I saw it I even
said to my parents there's a fundamental
moral dishonesty in this film Mom and
Dad I said that to them